this guy I just don't know it's just
just mind-blowing his guests Joe's guest
who has on the Joe Rogan podcast I don't
who is this guy he starts talking about
you know about Muslims treatment towards
Jews right and there I've we've had
programs on this in the past well let me
just cover this clip first what is the
position on Islam regarding Jews okay
well I mean we escaped Lebanon because
we were going to be executed okay bye it
wasn't by the Amish okay right so I said
you know what rather than kind of go
into a whole treatise here's what I'm
going to do I'm going to share with you
a montage of Imams from around the world
so this is not culture specific there's
an Indonesian Imam and Malaysian Kuwait
the Yemeni so these are at their sermons
this is at the mosque where they are
preaching what should be done to the
Jews and one of the particular Imams was
showing images of the Nazis bulldozing
skeletons into the ditches and he was
lamenting to God why God wouldn't you
give us the pleasure of exterminating
those Jewish rats why do you hate us so
much Jewish rats some version of that
right so he picked some random he's he
what he's saying that some Imam somebody
what what do you what do you say to that
yeah I mean this is what you do is you
cherry pick some random quote-unquote
Imam making some statements somewhere
and say see look look there's a a Muslim
somewhere who has some type of following
oh 10 people a hundred people we don't
even know and look he said something
wrong yeah there's like people like that
around the entire world who say really
ridiculous things the former chief
Sephardic rabbi of Israel has just
proclaimed that the only reason that you
as a non Jew exists on earth is to serve
Jews another Jewish religious later says
it's moral for a Jew to murder you and
steal your heart or liver if a Jew needs
one now maybe you think I'm making all
this up but I tell you the Jewish
extremists evil is too crazy for
buddy to make it up now you probably
haven't heard the rabbis words yet he's
not on Fox News CNN doesn't cover it but
it has been covered extensively in
Israel just not America of course rabbi
yosef is right
most Gentiles do serve the Jews we fight
their wars in Iraq and Afghanistan spill
the blood of tens of thousands of our
young men and suffer terrible injuries
and death to those nations we spend the
treasure of trillions of dollars in
these wars for Israel believe that there
is an honor and you that will not allow
you to be a slave to anyone much less to
such an evil power as Zionism even some
courageous Jews are joining the fight
against Jewish extremism and I salute
them right in all religions and in non
religions as well you know so this is
the problem is that you know you go and
cherry-pick something and you say oh
well that's you know that somehow
represents what all 1.7 billion Muslims
are saying that's that's again very
disingenuous that's the problem is that
you're not being honest with people and
you're misleading them to think that all
Muslims believe this thing because one
person said it okay what is their basis
for saying it is there any basis in the
religion our religion is based upon the
Quran and the teachings of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him did he
exhibit those things or did it
contradict what he's teaching none of
that stuff is there you know so when it
came to the idea of you know this how
Muslims treat Jews or how Islam is
supposed to be dealing with with Jewish
people and all of that this ideas is
ridiculous you know that Muslims have
been living with Jews in many parts of
the world specifically in Spain you know
in the past when you know Muslims were
actually in control of Spain for like
800 years Muslims and Jews were living
there peacefully there was no major
issues Muslims and Jews were living
peacefully in the Ottoman Empire in fact
when the Jews were kicked out of Europe
most of them were going to the Ottoman
Empire and they said that you know they
were they were flourishing at that time
in Spain it was their golden age so
relations between Muslims and Jews
outside of you know hot some hostile
political context
has always been generally fine and it's
still the case generally outside of any
political context where's this idea of
hatred from Jews and because of some
Imam code it's something right we can go
and we can start showing clips of
Christian preachers Habad calls
non-jewish women shiksas shiksa
literally means [ __ ] and it calls
Gentile girls chicks Elbe or little
[ __ ] now can you imagine the outrage
of Gentiles or any Christians called
Jewish girls little Jewish [ __ ] but
they do this all the time in the media
in fact sure that Jewish and Ericsson
whose non-jewish women from Catholics
from Protestants we could show Jewish
rabbis saying some something every
Gentile member of Congress voted to
honor this freak who says that every
Gentile and every Gentile congressman is
totally evil and every one of their
wives and mothers daughters is a [ __ ]
now that's true slavery when you vote to
honor somebody who says your mother is a
[ __ ]
and who tells you that your sole purpose
on earth is to serve we superior Jews we
can go and show atheists we can go and
show agnostics we can go and show UFC
fighters right which Joe was you know
MMA we can show a bunch of MMA people
making ridiculous statements are you
gonna go and say look this represents
all MMA fighters
[Applause]
go for Jesus no no Joe wouldn't think
that no one else would think that so you
don't do that you don't go pick a few
bad people make their statements and
then say well see that looks represents
everyone you know so now your audience
is getting a picture portrayed to them
like Muslims hate Jews Aslam teaches
hatred of you know Jews and now that
incites like these guys I know and now
you're hearing acid in the face you're
hearing female general I mean female
genital mutilation your honor kill man I
had a guest the other day he said I
watched Fox News I got my PhD thesis and
um in in and and what was it in one area
I forgot what it was and he said you
know it was making my blood pressure go
up listening to and I know the facts so
imagine someone is listening to all this
people are generally good people and
they're your D human dehumanizing them
and you don't have the facts but when
you facts check you know if you look at
it's one thing us saying this but when
you have indeed in the Jewish Chronicles
when you have professor academics
historians like this professed Jewish
professor David Warren Steen he wrote
the JC essay and he says aslam save jury
the Jewish people there's a great a
rabbi out there
rabbi singer mmm and he talks about the
Jews had it better than in any other
place no better placed and they went in
the Muslim lands yeah and I've started
all my life the rabbinic old school from
A to Z I come from the most traditional
what's called black hat world okay my
father is a great teacher Russia Shiva I
don't come from the traditional world we
all have our nut jobs are they're crazy
we have crazy Jews wackos and we have
crazy Christians and we have crazily
Muslim we all have our nut jobs welcome
to the what welcome to the show and
they're good people they're so sweet I'm
talking the people I interact but I'm
not saying the head of Isis is sweet
they're maniacs Isis went and came here
to Jakarta to kill Muslims
I mean there
still eat wicked what they're doing and
they abuse these texts in the Quran and
hadith to in order to kill people and
rape women and so on and all Muslims I
mean all majority of Muslims condemn
this but so I'm talking about people who
are serious who really care about God
who care about the truth who recognizes
the problem I'm talking to you everyone
else you don't feel listen for the show
shut her off and go somewhere else I
don't mean that disrespectfully but if
you can't separate the two then you're
gonna be a lower lip but if I read other
news I'll think that all Muslims are a
bunch of baby killers so dry planes into
buildings forget that garbage okay
that's nonsense
let's talk facts now and this is why
Jews don't know what this is beautiful
now with Christians my family was wiped
out by the by the Holocaust wiped out
almost happy just by luck my
great-grandfather came to America went
back and then my grandfather and
grandmother came when they were able to
come but there everybody was wiped out
my field I think 42 members of my family
were wiped out by the Nazis made a
parish in hell but those were all
Christians they were they were Nana
don't tell me the Nazis weren't
Christians believe me they had a belt
buckle on the waffen-ss got mittens and
if you whatever I don't want to get into
that point but it did not happen in
Islamic countries
okay the Holocaust did not happen in
Islamic countries it happened in Europe
Europe either directly Europeans
directly or passively murdered the Jews
to wipe down all of European jewelry
one-third of the Jews would just would
wiped out between 1942 and 1945 but Jews
were safe in the era now with the whole
thing in the Middle East
yes there's problems now but what do you
want to do you want to go throw gasoline
on a fire
and I mean when the Quran is critical of
Jews the critical of Jews believe me if
you read Ezekiel and the criticism of
Ezekiel - Jews who weren't keeping
terror the criticism from the Quran
Lahab dill doesn't touch Ezekiel 23
you were 16 it doesn't come close it's
much the Jewish Bible is much more
critical the Jews any Muslim who really
sincerely studies Judaism really studies
it not prop again on some dumb website
you know what I'm talking about who's on
the same dumb website you have the crazy
website say that Muslims are a bunch of
suicide bombers that kill people and I'm
not even through these filthy dogs say
this so I'm not talking about the
crazies but the serious serious people
one of the things that both Jews who
study Islam or Muslims which study
Judaism go whoa where we are the I mean
it's shocking how similar we are not
exactly the same let's get that clear in
the old days before you know the State
of Israel so on
they were crazies who persecute Jews but
frankly there is a reason why Jews in
the Islamic world whether it was in
Yemen or in Morocco did fabulous we did
better than the Muslims did the Muslims
were killing each other and the Jews
were doing great now were there
exceptions yes how did we get along so
well
my friends there's a reason why Jews and
Muslims got along better in Yemen got
along better in Morocco got along better
in Egypt got along better in Iraq than
Muslims and Muslims did when they were
unfortunately killing each other over
what over primarily politics you know
Albania how many did after the Holocaust
you know how many Jews were taken in by
the Ottomans by the by the by the
Albanians you know by the Muslims you
also have my good friend my co-pilot
who's a strong advocate you know further
because all this stems really for the
the theft of the the the Palestinians
land right this comes from that but
before its modern color but you have
Jews my friends my Jewish friends rabbi
Weiss you know who's been on the show
oh my
Israeli friend me co-pilot he's been on
the show when you take away people's
land and you destroy their homes
what do you incarcerate their father
isn't quite often their mother's when
you shoot their brothers and sisters in
the in their school in the school yards
this is what we get this is the price
that you pay as as a society that
maintains such a brutal oppression and
occupation against another people
there's a price to be paid and this is
the price that we pay in therefore they
both felt that they both held Israeli
government responsible because these
really government is responsible for the
reality that exists there now someone
just said that's an anti-semitic
statement you just made somebody is
pointing a finger and say this guy's
anti-semitic what do you have to say
about that
well I'm Jewish so being anti-semitic is
nonsense yeah why number two being
anti-semitic means being racist against
Jews I'm not racist against Jews but I
am critical of the State of Israel I'm
critical of Zionism which has really
nothing to do with Jews although they
claim to so there's nothing anti-semitic
about criticizing Israel a fact most
Jews don't even live there most Jews
never accepted Zionism so I don't think
there's that has anything to do with it
it's a claim that's being thrown out
when there's nothing else to say when
the other side the pro Israeli side the
side that supports the violence in
Palestine has nothing to say they say
anti-semitic well so they say
anti-semitic what if someone says look
he's just a self-hating Jew have you
heard this statement yeah well I
certainly don't hate myself
anybody else I think it's again it's one
of those things they throw at you and
then they've got no argument and these
people they love Muslims they get along
with they tell the facts a totally
different story an academic story but
what is this story yeah this story that
these guys he's picked some some some
rotten plum out here and exactly yeah
unfortunately what is that is that
genuine or disingenuous absolutely
that's that's that's uh that's why it's
important to have a variety of guests
yeah and they have a variety of opinions
that's the only way to arrive at the
truth yeah let's let's move on